im deutschen gibt es drei vokale mit
einem um laut köhl und heute zeigen wir
euch wie diese umlaute ausgesprochen
werden und vergleichen sie mit anderen
lokalen los geht's
[Musik]
wir fangen an mit dem das ist eine
mischung zwischen a und e
und wenn es mit einem kurzen lokal
gesprochen wird klingt dass er sehr
ähnlich zum e
zum beispiel in dem wort wende die wände
und die wende
das sind zwei unterschiedliche worte in
deutschen die fast gleich gesprochen
werden dass eine mit einem e
das andere mit einem die wende
die wende ein anderes wort zum beispiel
ist ändern ändern to change ende bringt
wird im deutschen auch sehr ähnlich
ausgesprochen also wenn der vokal kurz
gesprochen wird
ist eh sehr ähnlich zum ende ändern wenn
der vokal als langer vokal gesprochen
wird dann hört man den unterschied schon
deutlicher der arzt die ärzte diese
beiden worte haben einen sehr deutlichen
unterschied in der aussprache
ein anderes beispiel ist oder ehre ein
langes und ein langes die ära die ehre
im übrigen wenn ihr amerikanische
muttersprachler seite im englischen dann
ist es für euch vielleicht ein bisschen
einfacher das auszusprechen denn in
einigen worten wird das aaa im
englischen platz - und amerikanischem
englisch genauso ausgesprochen wie das
zum beispiel dass portman im englischen
im amerikanischen englisch wird das hier
sehr oder das hier sehr ähnlich zum
deutschen eu ausgesprochen und wenn ich
das englische wort
höhere würde ich das im deutschen
tatsächlich mit elf schreiben mm und das
deutsche äquivalent ist das wort man was
auch ein großer unterschied ist man und
mehr
der zweite um laut ist das öl das öl ist
eine mischung zwischen u und e
und ihr könnt es euch so vorstellen ihr
macht mit dem mund ein
und während ihr den mund so haltet wie
für ein versuch die reine zu sprechen
[Musik]
ungefähr so ihr könnt zum beispiel
dieses wort nehmen
versucht mal zu sprechen wohl also ohne
öl und er
der unterschied ist das so weiter vorne
gebildet wird wohl in der mitte ist für
englische muttersprachler oder zumindest
amerikanische englische muttersprachler
ihr könnt das vielleicht auch
vergleichen mit dem wort hört oder word
darin habt ihr auch ein laut der sehr
ähnliches zum leid deutschen öl- und das
kann man vielleicht auch ganz gut
vergleichen
hört hört denkt ich höre etwas diese
beiden lokale sind sehr ähnlich
zueinander
unser dritter umlaut ist das und das ist
vielleicht das schwierigste für euch
alle
das ist eine mischung zwischen u und e
und wieder könnt ihr diese gleiche übung
machen ihr form teuren mund zu einem
gesagt ein guru und das versucht die
aber statt einen hut zu sprechen
und plötzlich habt ihr ein
es ist tatsächlich dass der umlaut mit
dem die menschen am meisten probleme
haben deswegen hier noch ein paar
beispiele für euch bruder brüder fuß
füße
gruß größe hat den unterschied bruder
bruce größe fuß füße jetzt könnt ihr das
ganze noch mal für euch selbst üben
probiert es mal aus dass wir unser video
zum thema umlaute im deutschen wir
hoffen es hat euch geholfen die umlaute
besser auszusprechen und jetzt könnt ihr
noch ein mitglied werden von easy german
als mitglied bei tätscheln erhaltet ihr
jede woche vokabel listen transkripte
und interaktive übungen zu easy german
das ganze findet ihr hier wenn ihr auf
zetteln kriegt und hier könnt ihr easy
german abonnieren
wir hoffen ihr macht das dann bekommt
ihr immer eine nachricht wenn wir ein
neues video haben danke fürs zu sehen
und das nächste woche
das sind viele